une enquête passionnante de jean-michel
le lion sur le sport à cuba jean michel
a passé plusieurs semaines là-bas au
milieu d'une population qui pour un
tiers d'entre elles pratiquent les
sports un tiers c'est-à-dire 3 millions
d'habitants une équipe d'antenne 2 en
effet eu la possibilité d'analyser cet
effort sportif qui placent cuba au 8e
rang mondial compte au nombre des
médailles olympiques les athlètes
cubains sont montés 13 fois sur le
podium à montréal pour une population de
10 millions d'habitants c'est à dire
paris et sa banlieue
imaginez la france avec 65 médailles
dont 38 leider une politique sportive
définie depuis 1961 par fidel castro
présent sur les stades au milieu des
champions qu'il connaît
comment les athlètes d'état juantorena
kazamias léonard stevenson peuvent-ils
conjuguer études et entraînements
comment s'orienter dès leur plus jeune
âge les enfants vers des disciplines
olympiques
et puis pourquoi ce besoin de prouver la
supériorité du système dans le contexte
latino américaine bref une autre façon
de voir le sport pour tous
accu match